the key is to abandon your hopes and
dreams the other key is to fail very
early Masen mommy jetpack level
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] attack remember I'm a man
so to go telegin Wow dad just gotta keep
a nice goodness I'm dead see if I can
just cross the finish line in one piece
hurry so what happened my whole torso
exploded I seem to have a proclivity to
explode so maybe I could not do that now
who'd be able to get out of here okay
I'm just asking for a friend
I'm thinking maybe that that one time
and actually thought that I won the game
[Music]
mr. douche he's calm did I one obstacle
course yeah I win I'm Dwayne ur knowing
cube Amy I'm just the best look amigo
Ballmer kid is dead yeah I love that
happening to me okay I'm dead and my
baby is now it's Ward last break I was
really wondering when I could be poured
on this playthrough when the other
things gotta get interesting over here
all my son's head was ow that's a little
morbid don't you think why am I still
dancing hell's swore through take my axe
Thank You Satan I will try to kill them
all
hep what's this little kitty doing down
here hop thank you
whoa
BMX part whoa look how extreme this is
oh if I could be any better I would be
illegal wait oh [ __ ]
denim I'll try Zizi fight time dollars
exit way what attack 10% tab is 12 ah
take that kick man oh you were just my
grandpa that I just murdered and ripped
off his arm I don't care no mercy for
the weak no mercy for you either because
apparently it's exploded sorry but in
actuality I am nuts
thank God chill pal grandpa dad out
there
let's see kids attack random damage
random I think that maybe it's not a
gonna be as easy as you guys think it is
to kill me
Oh motion kinda this preemies Oh another
one of these huh okay crash your car
there's a surprise behind me to make
guess
- no one
[Music]
nothing like taking your family on a
friendly okay the brains on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no I'm doing it wrong whoa this is a
new twist oh this is not gonna work out
as clauses not my first try what I
didn't know what I was doing awesome run
3d I'm not even gonna try for the secret
finish there wait what does this do how
does this do for me my face don't be a
douche they told me to stop but I did
not listen run run I'm running why am i
running I'm running as fast as I can
oh my god
bye son have fun with the giant smiley
face I'm gonna go into victory nah you
missed me up there WWWE a World War we
won everyone
there died for us back down that was
World War we won WWE back down a death
run so let's see how deadly it could be
oh no you killed my son I'm so sad miss
me but stop spiking my bud please I'm
already dead stop you are an elegant
system take my son as a sacrifice
no just ow take one of these have them
have them for all eternity beautiful
people Oh God I thought I was gonna die
there oh no no mine jump mine jump oh
that's what it is
you said that was gonna be very hard you
douche Wow okay skills a thank you
skills me thank you skills me thank you
excuse me thank you
don't know what the hell I'm doing wait
a minute oh my god oh okay there's more
suck on these nuts
[Music]
minigames demo okay I know what I need
to do I need to get one of you come here
you come here no no no no you can't
escape me come on I was I just want one
of you come on come on you've come here
you [ __ ] come on yes alright you wave
it no Santa can fit through this gap
television get away no sad try for all
the good little boys that grows out of
that oh now
and I'm free free fallin and I'm free
[Applause]
let's go let's go let's go let's go hey
there we go that's a good speed cats I
won all my body parts are there
I said venge for all that you have done
come just come back here I just want to
talk with you if you utter one more word
okay I'm gonna rip off your arms if you
utter one more word okay I didn't hear
you say anything actually boy discount
okay can I say that the absurdity of
what's going on right now is actually
pretty high
that is amazing welcome to Thor drink
whoa oh my goodness well then this is
gonna be quite okay well obviously I
wasn't cut out to be four by many all
I'll smack the piss out of you you yeah
I hope you learned your lesson I smack
you with my bum bum stare run neon you
know I never actually found out what was
so difficult about these steroids okay
I'm starting to remember why bye son
have fun in death and I'll maybe not
join you soon okay ball throw been a
while since just a classic ball throw
everything I'm gonna no no no oh that's
that break dancing oh okay your knees
are not supposed to bend that way okay
test subjects don't press it the press
said
[Applause]
you're gonna touch that button and
you're gonna like it tortured bottle run
epic bye son you once again didn't want
to join me I'll just be going completing
this bottle run on my own I'm not even
looking at the screen anymore I'm
looking over at me
let's give it about Oh No what stay for
the box
Ted I gotta get out try to got it Ted I
got it I got giblet ended by pineapples
survive this fall well if you say so
what could go wrong seems okay so far my
dong has been amplified by this poon so
what's so bad about this doesn't seem so
bad I'm just gonna hang out here for a
few seconds while I get my breather on
yeah dump it out I swear I did this
before
and it went okay good you let go of me
thanks now what I wanted oh well then
okay this has been inconvenient
markiplier harpoon huh okie dokie Wow
Thank You shooter J for for markiplier
run you got it I'm gonna fail I'm gonna
fail No okay
was I supposed to come down here am I
supposed to be here is this what was
supposed to happen
I've got the kiss sucking my gears ah
son get out of there son
please need to ride bike you're being
very detrimental to my performance scuse
me thank you I'm dead but I won Thank
You J three Lycan
kill them all yes everyone kill that man
kills another man kill this lady kill
the stairs killed at the top of the
stairs maybe kill someone who's at the
top of the stairs possibly kill kill
them all kill the dominoes
kill kill kill them good I'm not killing
them quite so good cuz I'm going
backwards
cuz it's bad leg
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye